hey guys Riley here it's time to lock
the doors hide the kiddos and blow out
the candles and those jack-o'-lanterns
because we're gonna get a little freaky
here today on collider video the
Halloween season has officially begun in
the movie that put fear into the hearts
of babysitter's everywhere was getting a
new sequel 40 years after the fact
Halloween the movie the new movie that
is opens October 19th and it's billed as
a direct sequel to the 1978 classic of
the same name which is not confusing it
all right tune in the same name anyways
filmmakers David Gordon Green and Danny
McBride had a vision for something new a
better sequel the film that's a bit
closer to the tune and style of the
original cult favorite and when they
brought their idea to John Carpenter
well he agreed but that doesn't mean we
throw out the old movies and forget they
ever happen the shape aka Michael Myers
didn't become a staple of Halloween just
on the original movie alone and with so
many movies ready for a repeat viewing
and celebration of Halloween is time we
look at the top ten kills from the
entire franchise by the way everyone
spoilers for the entire series if well
if that needs to be said also viewer
discretion is advised because know this
is a top 10 kills video for Halloween so
it might get a little dicey so fair
warning so let's cue that music not that
music Halloween 3 season of the which
though you're a decent movie you get the
honorable mention for almost
single-handedly killing the franchise
well now cue the music
the music we love at number 10 is
Halloween part 6 the curse of michael
myers.slc punk
coming in at number 9 is Halloween 5
revenge of Michael Myers it's a
two-for-one and it comes when two lovers
sneak into a barn for a roll in the hay
literally not a smart move when the
shape is around and ooh a pitchfork
mid-coitus sure ruins the mood wouldn't
you say and extra credit points for that
creative use of the sky there Mikey
that's brew
but effective and at number eight is a
little bit of a cheat scene as you don't
actually see the kill in question but
however I think it's important to give
props to some a-list talent that got
their start in the Halloween movie no no
no Paul Rudd lives in the curse of
michael myers.slc what the shape had in
store for him you're a good man Jimmy we
hardly knew ye at number seven it's just
all sorts of wrong and it comes courtesy
of Halloween part 2 the 1981 version
mind you and not the Rob Zombie version
but hold tight to that one Halloween two
had the ingenious idea to set the movie
in a hospital the same night as the
original giving Michael all sorts of
toys to use on his victims when we see
the aftermath of one of Michael's first
kill dr. Mixter who was killed with a
syringe through the eye the nurse
Janet Marshall finds his body and
Michael surprises her from behind with
another syringe to the temple that's
gonna leave a mark coming at number 6 is
an all-timer for me and is classified as
the most tragic of the series but again
for me why because it doesn't involve
Michael at all that's right I'm talking
about the boy mistaken for Michael and
Halloween - Ben tramer was just minding
his own business on Halloween night when
dr. Loomis mistakes him for Michael and
confusion follows that police cruiser
slams into the boy exploding and burning
him to death
it's a tragedy one that could absolutely
happen in a night filled with confusion
over an escaped killer that's why this
gets the number 6 spot cracking the top
5 and landing in the number 5 spot comes
from one of Rob Zombie's movies I'm
actually glad we can include it here
nurse Daniels played by the legendary
Octavia Spencer yep the same Octavia
Spencer is brutally murdered by Michael
and the kill is all sorts of savage it's
truly one of the most realistic kills
from the entire series and a kill that I
actually had to look away from the hook
coming in at number four is one of my
all-time favorite kills from the
franchise because of its brutality and
what the [ __ ] it nests that's not a word
but I'm gonna go with it in Halloween
part for the return of my
Myers the franchise finally resurrects
the shape and good ol Mikey is back to
his killing ways when it's revealed that
after the events of part two Michael has
been in a coma for many years and only
awakens when it's revealed that Laurie
Strode had a daughter so Michael's up
and about and heads to Haddonfield where
terror and Sue's and a group of
survivors hide in the house with a cop
taking watch well we know what happens
here Mike he finds a way into the house
kills the cop and lays in wait for our
hapless victim Kelly to arrive with some
coffee and with a shotgun in hand boom
yeah that's right Michael is like Batman
he doesn't use guns well he uses a gun
to impale somebody through a door so
that's something this is one of those
creative kills horror is known for and
it's a worthy addition to the list
coming in at number three it's a classic
and a staple from the original Halloween
movie post-coitus Bob sporting those
wicked cool glasses hits the kitchen to
find some beer when he notices the doors
open off the patio he investigates and
well you guessed it the breathing from
the shape takes our attention and we can
only watch hopelessly his Bob searches
the kitchen for Linda who he thinks is
playing a prank on him so tell me kids
what is Bob Linde behind door number two
that's right Alex a knife through the
chest and paled on the wall this is V
kill one of the most iconic from the
series and shows the Deaf camerawork and
direction from a master of horror in
John Carpenter coming in at number two
as a classic and it's coming from the
first sequel again Halloween - nurse
Karen Bailey had been working at very
long shift at the hospital on Halloween
night no less and just wanted to relax
in a hydrotherapy tub with her co-worker
with benefits bud your doom bud based on
your name alone after the shape
dispatches bud he turns the temperature
up to 11 in the tub and after a
disgusting case of mistaken identity
oh that's just special and wrong Michael
drowns poor Karen scalding her so bad
her face falls off it's horrible Michael
you need some neosporin for that hand of
yours and finally the number one kill
the best kill in the Halloween franchise
comes shocker from the original 1978
classic Halloween it's the one that
started it all and it's Annie's death
her death is remembered for being a
study in nightmares escaped mental
patient tracks the girl from outside the
house watching her every move there's
barely any music just ambient sound as
she walks the house looking for her keys
so she contrived to see her boyfriend
the audience notices the car door is
locked
they hold their breath when she walks
the house alone and collectedly gasp
when she returns in the car door is
unlocked now don't go in there Annie
he's in the car the breathing crescendos
and the shape attacks strangling her and
slitting her throat there's no blood
there's no major bells and whistles an
innocent life is taken and it's set up
and filmed in such a real way that you
can't help but be scared shitless
Annie's death is the most powerful and
deserves the number one spot on this
list so that's it that's all the best
kills in the Halloween franchise but
what did I miss
what kill should have been added will
the new Halloween add to this list or
perhaps a few cracked the top 5 you'll
have to find out on October 19th
when Halloween lands and theaters so
drop in those comments add to our list
of favorite kills and remember to like
and share this video with your friends
your life may just depend on it
you
[Music]